[Risas]
[Música]
buenos días vengo primero a cumplir el
encargo de un querido amigo al que acaba
encontrarse aproximadamente una hora
este amigo tiene la extraña y
enriquecedora costumbre de despedirse
siempre con alguna frase que nos deja
pensando y cuando le conté a que venía
me dijo las recordadas a la gente en
algún momento que vivimos en una época
importante eso fue lo que me gritó y le
dije decir sí lo recordaré así que
cumplo con la tarea y recuerdo eso
vivimos en una época importante
lo segundo es que quiero invitarlos en
este momento a viajar al oriente al
oriente ecuatoriano hace 20-25 años
cuando las carreteras de nuestro país en
aquella región eran verdaderamente
imposibles peligrosas y coincide en
algún momento con un hombre que me dijo
venga al enseño donde hubo un milagro
hace una semana le dije que milagro y me
dijo venga el enseño llegamos al lugar a
una curva peligrosa con un abismo fatal
a un lado
y me contó que una semana atrás una
pequeña bufete se había ido al abismo
con un resultado terrible de cuatro
muertos y un sobreviviente y ese
sobreviviente en el milagro entonces
como lugarteniente político de la zona
me dijo voy a levantar aquí una estatua
en conmemoración y agradecimiento a ese
milagro
yo un poco un poco más escéptico le dije
mire si tiendo el presupuesto mejor como
decimos en ecuador en vez de una estatua
levantada
con todo respeto un policía ha costado
un reductor de velocidad
no no no no aquí hubo un milagro en fin
que decidió levantar la estatua
conmemorar el milagro y a los siete
meses
se lee se le repitió el milagro
en esa ocasión casualmente fueron
también siete muertos y dos
sobrevivientes se le duplicó el milagro
menos mal no le dio por levantar otras
dos estatuas
en todo caso se dan cuenta de lo que
hubiera significado en la vida de las
siete víctimas o en la vida de esas
familias el que este hombre hubiera
pensado aquel acontecimiento a través de
una palabra distinta
en vez de decir milagro hubiese dicho
una tragedia y hubiera salvado unas
vidas inclusive sin saberlo
podría haber sucedido pero no sucedió
todo por una palabra
vayamos vayamos más lejos y a otro
tiempo
vayamos a la francia del siglo 16 17 18
19 inclusive a una ciudad que se llaman
ant
ciudad próspera y encuentra uno así que
personajes muy preclaros de mucho dinero
traficaban
y comerciaban
con piezas de ébano a la semana al mes y
en 280 150 300 piezas de ébano qué
maravilla no personajes respetabilísimos
y en un momento uno de ellos quizás el
más poderoso exige al municipio a la
ciudad que le devuelva los impuestos que
pagó por unas piezas de iván o que se le
murieron
se le murieron unas piezas de ébano sí
y cuando uno investiga cómo se mueve una
pieza de iván descubre que esas piezas
de ébano eran esclavos
hombres y mujeres niñas niños
y que inclusive a una de esas niñas de
14 años le quemó el techo con un hierro
rojo para que no escapara
eran personajes respetabilísimos que
enseñaban buenas costumbres a sus hijos
y que los domingos después de misa en el
parque daban de comer a las palomas pero
eran traficantes de seres humanos de
esclavos
no no comerciantes de piezas de ébano
las palabras con ese poder terrible como
cortina de humo
para engañarnos para para hacernos creer
lo que sabemos que es mentira
para taparnos la realidad
pero así como tienen ese poder
terrorífica también las palabras pueden
construir mundos mejores vayamos
rápidamente al china oa japón somos
conscientes de que allí es una cultura
que respeta a las personas mayores ya
las personas mayores son un objeto de
veneración de consideración
en occidente no nos siguiente a las
personas mayores son los viejos viejo es
eso un trasto viejo un zapato viejo algo
desechable o lo que va de salida una
persona vieja como una escoba vieja algo
así
si vamos a traducir la palabra vieja
para una persona al oriente en japonés o
en chino no va a entender nunca porque
allá el concepto de persona vieja como
objeto desechable no existe lo quiero
explicar así
mandarín o en japonés yo escribo la
palabra 5 el número 5 y agujero 5
agujeros estoy diciendo yo porque yo soy
5 agujeros
a través de los cuales percibo a través
de los cuales aprendo el mundo se lo que
mis cinco agujeros mis cinco sentidos me
han enseñado
y qué pasa si en vez de cinco agujeros
escribo diez diez agujeros
estoy diciendo que soy esquizofrénico
que tengo doble personalidad no estoy
diciendo persona mayor
porque diez agujeros significa saber el
doble conocer el doble será el doble de
sabio entonces en occidente le decimos a
un joven vete hablar con ese viejo
y es terrible porque la misma palabra
que se utiliza para un zapato desechable
o desechado
allá no haya se le dice al joven vete
hablar con esa persona que sabe el doble
que conoce el doble
entonces necesariamente cualquier
persona todo el mundo se acerca con
respeto con consideración con admiración
a quien sabes doble
tendríamos que preguntarnos entonces en
nuestro mundo qué palabras que
expresiones han modificado nuestras
vidas de qué manera las han alterado hay
una frase que tiene por lo menos 2000
años y es una frase maravillosa quién de
ustedes quién de nosotros se opondría a
alguien que habla del respeto a los
semejantes maravilloso tenemos que
respetar a los semejantes todos aquí
somos chicos buenos cuidado con no
respetar a los semejantes
el problema del cerebro humano es que
funciona como un switch si nos enseñan
desde niño a respetar amar a preferir a
algo el cerebro guarda también un
espacio para rechazar para desconfiar de
lo opuesto
amo la luz llamó la tranquilidad
significa que no quiero la oscuridad ni
me apetece el desorden
si digo hay que respetar a nuestros
semejantes el cerebro también guarda
entonces un espacio para decir ajá
si tengo que respetar a mis semejantes
entonces puedo respetar a mis diferentes
y eso es lo que se ha visto a lo largo
de 2000 años de dolor y de vergüenza en
la historia de occidente respetar a
nuestros semejantes
europa durante siglos oyó a carne
chamuscada carne humana está buscada
porque fueron llevados a la hoguera los
que no eran semejantes los que creían en
algo diferente
y 20 millones de piezas de ébano fueron
secuestradas de áfrica
comprar las vendidas degradadas
marginadas convertidas en seres humanos
desechables porque porque esas piezas de
ébano
no eran semejantes a los traficantes
blancos
que se consideraban sí que estaban
cumpliendo con su deber respetar a sus
semejantes ellos nunca esclavizaron a
alguien de su mismo color no a los otros
sí
y por esa misma razón tortuga vamos a
los animales sobre disparamos a una
jirafa a un elefante porque esos
animales no son nuestros semejantes
habría que pensar si tendríamos o si
tenemos en verdad que cambiar a esa
perspectiva y esa frase
quiero recordar lo que lo que contaba
nuestro querido amigo al principio o lo
que pedía nuestro querido amigo
recuerda recuerda que vivimos en una
época importante y entonces a propósito
de eso recuerda una leyenda china
que dice que cuando un hombre cometía un
crimen y cuando era juzgado y condenado
las palabras finales que escuchaba eran
malditos frías perdón la expresión
maldito seas
y que tus hijos vivan en una época
importante
sin duda alguna coincidimos en que
vivimos en una época importante
tenemos que preguntarnos entonces cuál
fue el crimen que cometieron nuestros
padres
quizás nunca escudriñar en las palabras
que utilizaban quizás creerse chicos
buenos
porque durante miles de años atendieron
a que el principio de respetar a sus
semejantes
y olvidarse que realmente a quién hay
que respetar es al diferente por eso
cada acto de misoginia de machismo de
xenofobia
de homofobia cada todo eso está
respaldado inconscientemente por aquel
principio respeto a mis semejantes pero
como el otro no lo es entonces no tengo
por qué respetarlo
hago un llamado urgente
pensando en ese poder silencioso
pero telúrico de las palabras para mover
al ser humano y es empecemos a hablar de
respeto a los diferentes no enseñemos
más a nuestros niños respeto respeto a
los semejantes no seguimos respeto a los
diferentes
para que ellos no tengan como nosotros
que vivir en épocas
tan dolorosamente importantes
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]